well now I got add those sunglasses to
my wish list for Christmas the witch's
familiar so after getting a much bigger
much more active and generally much more
positive response to the last Doctor Who
episode video that I did then to anyone
prior to that I guess I'm just gonna do
spoiler videos from now on so that
that's your warning this is a really
terrific wrap-up from The Magician's
apprentice I just I love it just right
off the bat how it starts how it builds
how it plays out I love almost
everything about this episodes there's
some that picky things I don't get to
those but right off the bat establishing
Missy Clara Dara life which I called
your you'll remember I called that and I
even called that it was the same thing
that she did when death and haven't
happened and I was right on all that so
yay me don't mean to toot my own horn
but it feels nice to get that validation
I really like missing this I mean I've
enjoyed miss you up to this point I know
she rubbed some people the wrong way but
I've liked her up to this point this
episode I loved her I loved her and
Clara paired together and just the
nature of them going back and forth the
fact that Clara does not want him to
have anything to do with her but it
stuck with her and you see these sort of
adversarial relationships every now and
then but I can't think of too many other
examples where it's done like this with
Missy giving Clara so many reasons to
just walk away from this woman like if I
were to compare it to something like say
Loki and Thor teaming up in Thor the
dark world in that one which I think is
is sort of emblematic of most of the
times you see this sort of Oh bad guy
teams up with the good guys type
situation the point is usually to have
the bad guy really seem to truly be on
the side of the good guy so that when
they inevitably turn around at the end
it feels more of a ah it feels like more
of a betrayal even if you're expecting
it this goes completely the opposite way
we get reminded like every five minutes
and what a horrible idea it is to have
Missy right there next to you and I
really like that just from her casually
pushing Cara down into the sewer
threatening her with the point he's sick
in the pot I
very much like the pointy stick to come
back and be like Missy's new trademark I
like that stick I like a lot of what
goes on when Clara is inside the Dalek
I'm sure there are some people who
called that so ridiculous I mean that's
long-established is classic era episodes
where humans got into Dalek tank so what
I like is that the tank is automatically
twisting her words into something more
Dalek in some cases the exact opposite
of what she's saying like I'm your
friend I am your enemy like I love that
and not to mention it's quite a lovely
callback to asylum of the Daleks and
that version of Clara Oswin which was in
fact turned into a Dalek what I really
loved in this episode I loved the doctor
I think I definitely as of right now
this is gonna be episode that to me
defines Capaldi as the doctor because
even though I did like him last series
he he didn't seem to have much of a
defining sort of personality beyond just
kind of being grumpy and when I say that
when I think back on other doctors I can
just sort of pick simple phrases that
like sort of encapsulates them in the in
a nutshell Tom Baker was the bohemian
Christopher Eccleston was the wounded
soldier Matt Smith was the madman with a
box Patrick Troughton cosmic hobo etc
etc there really wasn't a phrase that
seemed to work for Capaldi's doctor yet
and based on what happened last series
now I know what he is the man's a rock
star and I love that vine I just feel
like this this is what I've been waiting
for from Capaldi like I said I liked him
up to this point but I was waiting for
that moment that makes me love him and
now I've gotten it and there's just so
many wonderful clever lines in here when
he takes Davros as chair and then leader
Davros Davros is making a joke I got you
the only other chair and Skaro
and of course Missy's got some wonderful
one line I mean there's just these great
funny moments that occur naturally
thanks to the characters and never feels
out of place I think the only thing that
maybe didn't work quite as well for me
as it could have and that this is I'm
gonna consider this nitpicky but then
some of the doctors interactions with
Davros particularly when Davros really
started playing on the doctors
compassion and like when he shut down
the
there and opened his realize him it
wasn't bad there was nothing wrong with
it it just it felt a bit maudlin it felt
like overdoing it of course by the time
we get to the end you res well it was
intact so yes it was overdone so it fits
but it did feel a little bit drawn-out
in the moments that it was happening
although that said I really do like the
Davros basically broadcasts what he's
gonna do by pointing out to the doctor
your compassion will be your downfall
and yeah he's right well he would have
been right had his plan not been
foreseen by the doctor and the doctor
completely turned it around on him and
again just in that wonderful clever ways
like fine I'll give you what you want
I'll give you a regeneration energy I
mean that's just a really cool
resolution and it it does the the sort
of funny little dance that the doctor
tends to do when it comes to destroying
Daleks which he does frequently of
course we don't really like the doctor
to kill people but the way they get
around that is generally by the doctor
sabotaging their plans so that
effectively these characters have killed
themselves which is again what happens
here the whole mercy thing might not
have worked for me if Daleks saying
mercy had not been a thing in previous
episodes and in case anybody forgot this
would go back to the Big Bang where a
Dalek asks for mercy from River Song it
didn't get it but it did ask for it
so the Daleks having a concept and
saying the word mercy is something we've
already seen and if it had not been for
that little connection I might not have
completely bought into the whole mercy
thing that that the note ends on but
because of that because they reach back
and they make that connection to
something you oh yeah you didn't just
pull that completely out of your rear
end that that is enough for me to buy it
and to have at work this is just a
terrific episode assess things off on a
terrific path I love it
he's now got the sunglasses instead of
the sonic screwdriver I mean that again
that's kind of the defining moment I
guess if I were to pick a single moment
he puts on the sunglasses and summons
the TARDIS yeah Rockstar so I think
that's it for me on this one I just this
was great and now I am even more pumped
I already was for the rest of this
series so for me it took a series plus
to get that defining moment of Capaldi
for me to really start loving him did
that happen for you in this episode have
you had that fall in love with him
moment yet if you have let me know what
it is if you haven't what kind of thing
might turn you around and get you to
love this guy because I now officially
do drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it and until next
time this council is adjourned